(TurboScribe.ai로 음성 변환됨. 이 메시지를 제거하려면 무제한으로 이용하세요.) 제 이름은 브라운 선생님이고 이것은
제 2학년 언어 수업을 위한 비디오입니다.
온두라스 코마야과에서의 코로나 격리 기간 동안에요.
안녕하세요, 여러분. 모두
행복하고 손을 잘 씻고 있기를 바라요.
오늘 우리의 목표는 흔한 동사들의 철자를 쓰고
슬라이드 쇼를 보면서 그것들을 정확하게 발음하고
단어들을 함께 써보는 거예요.
동사가 무엇인지 아는 사람 있나요?
동사는 움직임을 나타내는 말이에요.
우리가 '사이먼 가라사대' 게임 했던 거 기억나요?
몇 주 전에요?
네?
'사이먼 가라사대'에서 배운 단어들
중에 어떤 것들이 있었죠?
제가 기억하는 몇 가지는 이래요.
Play, walk, run, eat, jump, stomp, clap,
drink, read, write, sit, close, open.
다른 것도 아는 거 있나요?
더 기억나는 거 있어요?
같이 좀 더 연습해 봐요.
나중에 발음 시험 볼 거예요.
이 활동을 위해서는 연필과
종이 한 장이 필요해요.
그림들을 보고 여러분이 보는 그림에
해당하는 단어를 쓰세요.
그림들을 이해하게 되면, 여러분은
반 친구들과 의사소통 게임을 할 수
있을 거예요.
먼저 이 활동을 같이 해봐요.
자, 1번은 clap, clap (박수치다)이에요.
이렇게요.
2번, 2번은 close (닫다)예요.
close, 이렇게요.
3번, 3번은 drink (마시다)예요, drink,
drink, drink.
4번은 eat (먹다)이에요.
eat, eat, eat.
5번은 jump (점프하다)예요, j-u-m-p.
J-u-m-p, j-u-m-p.
6번은 open (열다)이에요, o-p, open,
open.
7번, play (놀다/연주하다)예요, p-l-a-y.
8번, 8번은 read (읽다)예요, r-e
-a-d, read.
9번, 9번은 run (달리다)이에요, n
-r-u-n.
10번은 sit (앉다)이에요, s-i
-t, e가 아니에요, seat가 아니라, s-i-t,
sit.
11번, 11번은 stomp (쿵쿵거리며 걷다)예요, s-t,
stomp.
12번은 walk (걷다)예요, walk.
이 글자는 소리가 안 나요, walk.
마지막 거, 13번, 13번, write (쓰다)예요, write.
이 글자는 소리가 안 나요, write.